ah
hello everyone thank you rafa for the
introduction as already mentioned I
am a box engineer at bq bq we make
mobiles but we also make a lot of
software to allow us to be able
to make all those
mobiles so I wanted to tell you a
little about the talk on this side  I am going to
tell you a little about how we were at
bq a few years ago, how we have been
evolving and how we have ended up
using the cv vernet google platform,
so this is more of a
trajectory about four years ago more or
less we saw we were a small company
we were few  employees we did not need
many services we had only 10 or 15
all of them ran in
virtual machines with their own hardware it was
quite normal and all the
provisioning was done
manually locks by ssh runs more apt
tunstall everything very manual at most you
stayed a few scribes  that was the
deepest you could go
besides of course i didn't have  os
high availability none of the
services
and the scalability will be vertical and
quite expensive in
the end well we were
constantly worried about the persistence of
the data our data was on
our own hard drives it could
break we could lose it and
there is a global ignorance of the
infrastructure that each administrator
of systems each systems technician
when he was going to take off did it
moderately how he could install the
machines how he could and how he knew and you did not
know very well what
your colleague had done and when you had to
fix it what was really in that
machine  installing the
deployments were completely manual
we have all done deployments by ssh and
ftp it was what was carried out four
years ago and it was great
and of course there were many
interventions in all the companies
of department 7 we have a
guard service a don koll service someone
who  have to watch out when  a
service stops working and that person
receives an alert or a call at
night and you have to wake up
well four years ago and a
colleague of mine who is here knows
perfectly well the week I was on
duty it was your turn to be on
duty  I didn't sleep for a week and you came to work with
dark circles under your eyes every
day, so where we've been we
've been growing we've been getting
more services and the center is certain
imminent to the cloud it was there we didn't
start dealing with
virtual machines in google cloud  and the
provisioning in the machines
using specific chef salt software,
an orchestration system that
allowed us to replicate the environments in an
easy
way, without manual interventions, everything
was perfectly documented, well,
we began to have a little bit of high
availability, horizontal scalability, we
alternated the cloud and not worry about it  of the
data less interventions and in the end
well things  s were beginning to
be a little better made
and in the end
we had to take a step because
we started because we got to use
vernet is good because in the first place it was
the technology with which we could
take off the docker
containers the care containers you know everything
packages its exportable application it can
work in any environment in
production in pre-production in local you
forget you have heard everything sure the
typical of in my local works
well because we were things with which
we wanted to finish
gubern & export that cubero net that was
the most orchestration system  stable
that existed at that time we are
talking about two and a half years
ago now there are other
solutions but at the time it was the most
stable a project led by google
they alone were going to give us things that
we were trying to find that we will have to
work on it as  that he was
going to worry about the health of our
nodes when we were going to deploy one
to  The application was going to worry about
keeping our application alive and
healthy at all times and then on top of
that it gave us another series of advantages such as
helping us manage
deployments, automatically taking care
of all log management and allowing us to
integrate with monitoring solutions
and because it contains engine it
contains beijing it is the version although
cloud as a service of cuber net is we
do not have to manage any machine we do not
have to manage the master and we always have
updates in a simple way
also they were incubated from many
updates and having it on the
google platform  in
engine contains because this becomes much
easier it is absolutely integrated with
all key google services
the persistent volume for
load launchers auto scaling iam and also its
own functionalities that you can only
have if you have them in contain engine
such as auto  repaired of
nodes or not of pools and good cos
you really have to have it in your own
virtual machines to use the content
engine is ridiculous it is practically the
same I mean that you have a cluster
of less than five nodes you pay
absolutely nothing more if you have a
class of five nodes you pay an
extra cost for the master that  it is practically
invaluable it would be what it would cost
you to have that master's degree separately
and well in the end where we are now
we have more than 300 services all the
services we use a lot
of google cloud services if not to say
practically the entire portfolio
approximately 90%  of the
web services portfolio we are using it
we have the entire automatic approach
that we wanted we have
high availability auto healing
horizontal ladder very fast there are no
direct interventions in fact
those same people who
suffered four years ago know that now it
is an anecdote  receive a call
at night and we have achieved ta  Also,
even developers can
deploy their own applications
in the cloud infrastructure,
as we have been able to deploy as
often as vernet is to launch
our applications in high
availability, well, for this,
I would first like to clarify some
concepts of residence against high
availability to understand  each of
them not when you say that a system is
resident what you are receiving is that
by itself it is capable of functioning and
keeping functioning however high
availability is that whatever
happens your system will not stop
responding
a resident system  For example, at
night the application may crash and it will take
a while to restart and continue to
work in a high availability system.
resident and which
of them in high dis  availability
that offers us toys and contain in the
gym to have residence not
first is resilience because it is in
charge of managing the nodes
also there is a novelty in that vernet is
from covers of 1.6 we can activate
as a beta option only in content in the
option of  auto reper which directly
contains the engine analyzes our
nodes it is in charge of knowing if it has any
health problem or not and automatically
the authors- for it is in charge of auto
updating our new ones also if
we want it has that option and well and how
vernet is in buckets  we can display
specific work glows replication
controls diploid meant that thanks to
the health sex we can make our
application resident it means
that if our application at some
point one of the messages that we display
from our example and less vision
controller stops working q vernet is
automatically takes care of
restarting it or sending it to a new one
within the cluster  That is not why we say
that it is resilient
and that Cooper offers us times and contains an
engine to have high availability,
well, we are going to go over a series of
functionalities that
many of them have recently been incorporated into cover
net, it is that it allows us to take off our
applications and that, in addition,  These are
functionalities that we have used
at bq to take off our
applications in high availability to
absolute high availability does not exist
but thanks to them we can get
a little closer the first of
them is pod affinity and anti affinity
what does this mean good to be able to
fidel and definitive will allow us to
specify how we want our
posts to be deployed in the cluster
with each other
let's imagine in this case we have two
not worth it and we are going to want to deploy in
these two nodes an application that is made
up of a front end an application
with  a front-end and a cache that are
placed up front for
good high availability  or well, we are going to
deploy,
we are going to achieve, we are going to configure in what
vernet is so that there are two replicas
of each one of them, they cover a test, it
will automatically put a replica
of each one of them and
this image is going to distribute them to our nodes
What we have here would ideally be
what we would like q vernet s to do, but it is
not always going to be like that in our
heads. This would be ideal,
one of them in each node, so
that if one of the nodes fails,
then we continue to have this  application
deployed in the other we do not have it two
in each two decades in such a way
that if it does not fail we always have another
this would be the idea however
something like this can happen to us that all the posts
fall on the same side is quite
rare but  It can happen in this case
obviously if one of the nodes
stops working the node where
all the posts are our application
will stop working completely something
more likely to happen would be this from here  uí
two have not been distributed in each node but
the two are equal in such a way that if
one of the nodes stops working
exactly the same thing will happen to us
the application cannot work without the
two components but one of the two how
can we avoid  this is good because with
interpol affinity and anti affinity
interpol affinity agent affinity
defines which posts you don't want to be with you prefer
not to be you want to be or you prefer to be
is a property that is displayed
inside the pot property
and allows you to define that type of thing
so for example  in the example
we were talking about we could define an
affinity between the cache pod and front and
an anti affinity in each of
them separately because this is good the
affinity because we want to try that the
cache post and the front be as they
are together well  they are applications
that go together with the pool affinity
we are going to achieve
the lowest possible latency between the two
this is an example with a cache a front
but maybe if you are already interested with your
application and the database you are going to
try to get them to be in the same
mode and reduce latency and anti-
affinity because it is going to achieve the
situation that we wanted that they were at least
separated in new different
In the past, when vernet is this, you
could achieve it in a slightly
more homebrew way, which was by specifying a
fp port of the host that you wanted to be
occupying, and since there is only one spd port
available in the game,
something was necessarily separated, but it
was like a  trick of the almendruco to be
able to do this that today can be
done well with the affinity entity
we are going to explain another concept that
surely sounds familiar to many of us, it
may sound a little more familiar to you, but this
in particular the pod disruption budget
to be able to understand  this concept
we are going to see first
a topic that surely many of you are
interested in the topic of updating
a cluster ok
what do we do when we use  we create a cluster
when we are going to create a cluster
we have two components in
perfectly separated governors one is the master
and the other are the nodes where we execute
our applications we update
them separately in the event that we are
using content in jim google is
completely in charge of updating our
master and in fact in most
cases this is completely automatic not
even we realize
that the cluster is updated the
master
in the case of the nodes is an operation
that we have to carry out
manually the trigger we have to
run manually
and container engine gives us the option to
update the cluster nodes through
an option a button on the wii or a
command problem or through the rest interface
what this does is trigger a
series of events and one by one  it is
updating the nodes the process of
updating a node is not to apply a
series of binary patches or replace  launch
configuration files and turn
new binaries is responsible for emptying the
node where all the posts are and creating
a new node with the new version of
cuber net is then
that is what it does for the moment
they have to update this new one
here what it is going to do is a
view that what it does is make
all the posts that are in that node
go to senate and then
delete it and create a new one, in this
case our application is valid as it is
deployed in such a way that  we have more
than one replica we would not have a problem
because all its messages would be moved to
other nodes and at the moment of the change
we would not have quality of service of
our application
what happens when we have a
slightly larger cluster than the one we have
seen previously instead of four
nodes  we have 200 new ones because in this
case the update that
google proposes directly to us in a basic way
does not compensate us because it does not compensate us
because it is sequential  ial and one by one
we are not going to be updating
the cluster every time there is a
new update that there are also
quite a few updating all the new
11 because it takes a long
time to update each new one
approximately 5 or 10 minutes
so the proposal is
doing it several by several
does exactly the same thing but with
several nodes at the same time what happens when
you do this because it can happen that your entire
application is contained within
just the nodes that you just loaded
in the cluster and that you have a
quality  of service to see before assures us of
resilience surely
after a few minutes 15 or 20 minutes as
soon as all this has returned to
normal your application is not so much
yes but it will be 15 20 minutes in
which it has not received a single  request
because your application to this location
this is what would happen we run out of
our application and the way to
avoid it is to use the could action
budget  that I was talking about earlier
basically applies to a pot and a
display men
and you simply indicate what is the
minimum number of posts that
you always want to have present in your cluster
so that when you go to try to
do this operation the drain cooper
net is in a  of them it will tell you 429
http your mini request means that
you cannot load the senate because
otherwise you will not fulfill the power of smart in
variette that you have just defined it is not
accumulated this operation is not
executed automatically you have to
try again later but at least it
will ensure that your application will
continue to run
another point that is of course super
important when deploying an
application with altadis auto
scaling units that everyone likes
then the  auto scaling well let's
see is this application schema that
can be defined by a cache the
cache is defined by a deployment
that has two spots  Ok,
a front that has another project,
we have two posts, and another
totally dependent system, which is a worker
with two posts, is replicated, okay,
all of them can scale
horizontally, there is no problem,
these are the types of fish we
have in q vernet is one of them  chicken
autoescalera that what it is going to do is
just what we were saying about a
mind display and it has two posts
at the moment autoescala is going to put
3 4 5 6 as many as we want and of
course the no autoescalera because
we can create all of them  the posts
that we want but if we do not have cores and
ram where to put them they are not worth much
then the option of not the autoescalera
what it does is also create new
nodes
the horizon to the power autoescalera is
based on cpu at the moment with investment
in the stable version or  beta version
I always everything I talk about here I
usually talk about stable or beta
the difference between an alpha version or
a beta version is that the versions
alpha ones or of course they are alpha pencil can
be broken and also google in
container engine never takes you
alpha functionals to production classes
recently it gives you the option to create
an alpha cluster but what to do to the
fan does not assure you is the ea  and also
automatically after 30 days it
destroys them only to test
novelties so whenever you see that
there has been a new novelty and the novelty is
alpha surely surely it is not
available to use in continuing in
china I do not know that it is an alpha cluster
good going back to
this horizon autoescalera is based on the use
of cpu at the moment it is already as
alpha to be able to use custom metrix and
memory that is to say that shortly
as soon as it goes to beta we will see it in the
contains of engine and the only thing
we have to define is minimum  and
maximum replicas minimum and maximum replicas
and a threshold of 50 percent is valid so
that the government
knows which cpu units correspond to that
50% of cpu that we have is  taken we have
to be able to indicate we must indicate
resource limits that also before lazio
colom put a lot of emphasis on this and it is
very important not always everything that we
display in our reproduction class to
make sure that we have
displayed it with a memory limit a
cpu limit for  that you do not owe
the resources of the cluster, well, by
defining the cpu and memory limits,
we can then make use of the
percentage in the horizontal by
autoescalera
the self of autoescalera is directly
integrated with the cloud provider supports right
now world cloud contains the
engine azure and  amazon and it has to be
fully supported and fully
integrated so for now these are
the ones that exist
and a little else also takes into
account in the limits of our posts it
knows how much memory and how long it has been
using it is using in our class
thanks to the  limits that we have defined
if I do not cover minds you cannot know it and
you will create nodes of  In a dynamic way, in
terms of those values that we have defin
d, the e
se with which he creates posts for you and t
e way that the vernet wanted you is in the a
to scaling, it is qu
te enough to seek to say that at the m
nimum that he needs to create them, he will creat
you  new bots and then it will be
much more relaxed when it comes to
distributing it
we are going to talk about another functionality that is
not least important
livenation reynés props that will
allow us together with
everything that is consecrated from auto scaling
make sure that our application is
running
james prop simply  it is a
typical monitoring check that allows us to
know if the application is
running, it can be checks like a
command, an http check, and in the event
that our pod does not meet that condition,
what vernet is going to do is
restart it, the redín is  prop this I
would like to tell you a few more things
because it is quite interesting and many
people do not pay due attention to
lend the rhein is prop  what it will
indicate to cooper minds is when
our application is ready to
be ready to receive requests to
be working
in such a way that for example if we are
auto scaling and we do not have defined a
meetings prop automatically as soon as
auto scale creates a new post  with
our application cooper net is going to
start sending requests directly
to that new one for and maybe that little bit
is still starting up, it's not quite ready
to have
new requests so through meetings
pro we can make it pass a
specific test that cooper puts  check and
you can know that you can directly
send requests and to answer
another thing
that allows us to have and allows us to
do allows us to have this application
in high availability and perhaps there will be
some costs are the thirty and tolerated
jones we are going to see what they are first
I wanted to talk about no about affinity
no it's definitely one more it's something
that takes the  curantes pencil from
practically its beginnings and what it
tells us is with which nodes we
want our post to run
we can define an affinity of
preferred or required but basically
with this we can make our pod
go to some new specifics we
might have  in those nodes some
physical disks and locations and we want you to make use
of them or who knows what but
you want those posts to go to those
specific nodes however what we
cannot do with one of affinity is
and the opposite I mean yes  there are some
nodes that we have in our class of
rulers because our cluster of
rulers we deploy all kinds of
applications
there are some nodes that are specifically
placed there to be used by certain
spots and we do not want any more to
use them
we would have to
use no definitive in absolutely
all of them  the nodes to tell them not to
use them what you cannot do with one
of affinity is to tell the nodes  you
don't want them not to be used by the
wells
so that's why the times and
television arrive with a time you can define at
the node level you create a time in a
node and the time
what it tells you is if you want to have
within that  node that posts you do not want to have and
through it tolerate jon that you apply in
the pot you make it possible to fulfill the time
that you just specified within the time
you can define three types of actions no
schedule prefer no schedule or no execute
or the positive value schedule or
you prefer that and what it comes to mean
is no schedule is that
you do not necessarily want any post that carries the
action of tolerase jon in particular I
do not know they do not cover tests do not send it that no
what when you go to create you tell
when  What do you want to raise a little?
No, if it doesn't meet this condition, it won't
send it like that. Not specifically, it will
look for another new primer. No schedule.
Preferably, it won't send it. It's the
node, but if there are no resources available.  s
in the cluster it will not use it, it
will use it and not execute it
is that directly even the title
explains are time to a node that already has
messages in execution
if they do not meet the condition it will
remove them that way ok then so that it
can be seen  in h cut you have a node
you have detected that maybe it has a
hardware problem or a
connectivity problem and you don't want
applications that you have in production to
be affected but nevertheless there are
other applications that can
continue to use the senate without any
problem  one time with 9s cut the
production applications that are at
risk of having a loss of quality of
service will be sent to other nodes and
however in the applications that can
continue executing they will continue
executing and without any problem
then another way to scale mixing
everything a bit  what we have been
talking about the escalating car the times and
tolerase jones well I know that many
like me believe in the virgin of the fist  or
closed from the brotherhood then whatever it takes
to save us some costs because it's
always good no then I don't know if you
know about the same victor
machines from google that basically
are 80 percent cheaper but with two
cons one than the maximum time they
can  being alive is 24 hours and the
other drawback is that within those 24
hours they can die at any time
so we are a bit annoyed
however we were talking about Cooper
Metes already giving us resilience that
even if a node will no longer be
available it covers a test if  it will
ensure that your application will continue to
be running on other osa nodes if
a node becomes unavailable because it
is turned on bolt and it dies it has reached the
end of life cycle
cooper net es will automatically
make sure to move those spots
to new ones that yes that  they were
alive however the option of having a
cluster completely with 12 preventive
is a good idea because they can
all die at the same time  or it may be that there are no
preventive james resources available
in google cloud and you do not have any
mode in the cluster then it is a new
tone is a good idea then what
can we do to save costs to be
able to continue using preventive litos
machine at our pleasure of cooper  etc
we could have something like this for example
imagined our application that runs
in production is worth
the service that is the
internal launcher instead of a display meant
we have two display mentz that we can
have it perfectly the launcher
will balance according to the labels at
21  the diplomantes will be
executed normally in any new
cluster and the other diploma meant will
have a tolerase jon a preventive
james that we have defined would be able to
execute in virtual machines
preventive those that we
have previously labeled with a time that
only  those that have this
television and we could even define
a target cpu different from  in such a way that
those that are in pre-sale and world games
scale much faster
and well, as I know that you are all
excited about all these news
and want to use them and many of
you may not want to use it, get on
jim since will is 1.6 we have
the tool available  cube admin
that solves the ballot that
recurring classes took off and it is
complicated and we can deploy a
cluster with exactly two commands, a
command to raise the master and another
command to raise the rest of the
new ones, so I encourage you to
use it and  until the end of the
talk